hey guys so right now we're at the pier
in Santa Monica and they have this all
set up for splatoon the Nintendo game
and you basically are running this
obstacle course and in the game you're
like this little swim girl and you gotta
go and you gotta fight so everything is
set up to replicate parts of the game
and we're gonna run it this is like
real-life video game I'm overwhelmed
okay so we gotta go get suited up now
because half of it
Wow Oh play
I'm suited up through the booth yeah
anyway we are about to run the course
and to determine who's on whose teams
there's poor people Jay's in their name
so we feel like somebody's gonna fall
off the top like that like now to pick
up I feel like I'd be the new hope you
are you two again
so there is a strategy at the end the
term is cover yourself in it yeah hi
guys like cuz we play the game and I
have no idea
boy we got this is real life though
right not to do I so nice too much gonna
be bad
sorry there are that many girls but you
are allowed to cover your body and roll
okay getting food for a hollow right now
and things are getting crazy missile
we're gonna look like
Oh
sorry purple team where that roller down
pull it down I just dean is just making
this her own Incan swimming pool
careful teams weapon so our room team is
right there remember as soon as the
referee gives you two go ahead
you need to ring that buzzer who's it
going to be purple team Green Team now
as a chance to make some noise crowd
cheering we was down to the final purple
team taking the run hotter parts verbal
team wins
Wow
pants I don't know it's gonna be a good
one
oh geez Kairi good but these guys pretty
good
all right we're gonna give those guys a
chance to catch her breath Oh
craziness I thought it looked very very
messy I was going to say not clean
yeah I'm not going did you play the game
yet I haven't played the game is the
game fun it's really fun actually have
little tenths of a time I did have a
good time did you have a good time I did
it was really fun I wanted to run the
course again but then I thought about
the message it would an outing her yeah
and I really wish we could have been out
of 17 I know well fortunately purple
teams dominated unfortunately not a J in
your name because that's how they
children all the days but on the one
team yes I'm right after I'm Akay so
watch look at this we thought that was
us we look at that alright let me go
home and shower now so yeah